when I have a community of people who are weaponizing mentally
ill women to try to destroy my life in court. >> Do you
think that people could earnestly hate you for the way that you've
conducted yourself on the internet for the past 3 to 5 years?
>> That has nothing to do with this. I'm not answering.
>> Yeah, there are people who are laughing at Connor standing
up to you cuz you're acting like a petty, childish tyrant. >> So,
so hold on. You think JTOK, Queman, esports Batman, they all
hate you for delusional or non-serious reasons? >> Yes.
Uh, I
it's a it's a great day today. Oh my god. So, if you guys missed
it, Counter Points had a stream today and he was talking to Doobie
and then I think eventually Destiny hops on and dude it goes
it goes pretty crazy. There's a lot of fighting back and forth
and Dubie will make a point of okay well when Desi doxes people
he's putting people's family at risks and he's like creating
what we would call a permission structure or a a possible lens
by which people will judge him and act against him right that
while we principally
he is sort of losing his moral high ground to say people should
defend me against these these kinds of actions right I like I
still am very vehement we don't stoop to that level we don't
try to invoke real world harm on people we don't do anything
like that right And this idea, this concept of like describing
what Destiny's outlook
sort of sews for him. Destiny describes this as Dubbie trying
to log his child. That's how he will describe it to people, right?
And now Connor finally like calls him out on this today and the
crash out is crazy.
that like I'm talking pages and pages and pages of all caps logs
spamming repeatedly over and over again about
like like about Connor, how Connor's a loser. So, as a result,
Destiny's posted this today. Right here is the the big paragraph
that we're going to focus on today. Okay. So, as of today, I
do not want anything to do with Connor/Counter Points. I will
not appear. Didn't even spell his first name right. One end man.
Like this guy doesn't even know the people he claims are his
friends. Didn't know Erdite's degree. Doesn't know how to spell
Connor<unk>'s name. Like it's just little things like that
that really sort of drive home how much he considers other people.
And it's just it's wild. Anyway, I will not appear on any panels
or shows with him. I will enforce my copyright against him if
he is reacting to my content in a non-transformative way. Dude,
that's crazy to be like, I'm actually going to sue Connor. I'm
going to DMCA Connor. I'm going to DMCA him. This is This is
the funniest thing to me, man. L M AO. I have zero knights, zero
defenders, zero people besides food shops who can actually put
up a non-cocked argument. It's actually insane.
It's like,
why is nobody articulate or intelligent defending me? This this
perplexes me. Why would nobody want to defend me? Why did all
the intelligent people I used to hang out with go away and now
nobody intelligent will defend me? Why is it that only some total
zombie will defend me? Hm.
It must be Jay- Sock's fault. It must be Dubbiey's fault. It
must be the Starker's fault. It must be everyone else's fault.
It couldn't possibly be my fault. That could that doesn't make
any sense, guys. It couldn't be my fault. It's everyone else's
fault.
I have no defenders.
Here we go. >> My uh my chief mod. So uh what Destiny what
I started this morning's stream with is uh the reasonable ask
that I heard you articulate that I'm okay with is do not allow
snarkers in your community to endlessly talk about me or why
I'm no longer associate fraternizer.
So if I were to go around and ask there has not a single time
in the past six months been a one plus hour voice call with you
being here talking about or >> Let's try to play nice just
so we can get through the substance and then if we want to be
mean after the substance then we can be mean after the substance.
Um to my >> you seen here at all? I think he's seen here
and I've never been a subject to that conversation as people
never been a thing that he's nobody's ever been here for instance
I've been brought up and >> well the issue is if if there's
a bunch of people who like DGG in Conor's community or if they're
DJers in Connor's community they're going to press Dubie about
it cuz you've made a huge thing about Doobie is Dubbie supposed
to just say no I can't talk about that no sorry I cannot invoke
Destiny I cannot invoke Stephen Destiny Bennell in any other
Discord what is he supposed to do
a little bit. I'm asking you, Connor, slow to ask your server.
When I do a pole at your server, none of these people would say,
"Oh, no, no, no. We've never heard somebody say, "Quick, grab
Dubbie." Destiny is the topic of the conversation for Doobie
to come in and do all of the ordinary smears. Right. >> I
would I would I would appreciate a 30 second stance. >> Why
would that not be expected? That's literally every Discord. Hey,
someone's here on one side of the issue and we need our expert
on the other side of the issue. That's every single Discord ever.
If Doomie knows like a bunch of these arguments and people like
know that he knows it and knows that know that he argues it like
this is what will happen if let's say someone's arguing on a
point right and they've heard it from somebody else and they
can't argue the point perfectly they'll go oh I'll go grab this
guy who's who I've heard argue it he knows the point >> answer
to my knowledge the answer is no the people that I would ask
if this had ever happened in the past 6 months are Tae uh who's
my former editor and former chief modellrunner
who's my current chief mod and I would ask them if they'd ever
seen anything like that.
>> Can you drag one of them in here and ask >> Yeah,
sure. Uh Fel was on here 30. >> You think Destiny knows
he could just ignore the Starkers? No, he doesn't know this.
He doesn't know this. He doesn't care. He is fully invested in
getting Dubbie to stop from talking in like 20 person VCs about
that he's about how he's a bad person. And by the way, I guarantee
you Doobie doesn't go in and just bring this stuff up all the
time. I guarantee you people bring it up to Doobie as often as
he brings it up. At
>> seconds ago. Um, do you
>> basically because Wick is like a joint space, right?
And Dubbiey's like sitting there, people will join just to press
Dubbie on this stuff and that's not his fault. Hold on real quick.
Um, before I create like another chat, I suppose um I just want
to ask a quick question. Um, Destiny, do you have anything that
you want to say to Dubbie or you want uh feedback from Dubbie
on? And Doobie, do you have anything that you want to say to
Destiny or give him feedback on? Because if you guys don't have
>> I would have a mutual one-on-one. Duby's goal is to
destroy my life. Conor, you're [__] [__]
That was the dumbest question you've ever asked in your entire
entire life.
>> These people these people who just won't lay down when
I threaten them. They're trying to destroy my life. Oh yeah.
What are they saying? Well, they're talking about me shine without
consent. Well, you admitted to that. They're trying to destroy
my life.
>> Do you have anything that you want to talk to him about?
Yes or no? >> Well, I mean, we can I mean, we can run this
we can run this one thing. Did you do you find his arguments
for why uh it's acceptable to my and his mom who live in a separate
state from me? Do you find those arguments compelling
>> as a description?
Yes. The point Duby is making again I'll just remind everybody
the point Duby is making is that if you operate on Destiny's
level of morality that would be okay to dox people around him
because that is what Destiny does. That is the description of
the world Destiny has created for himself right and the people
who defend him. that that basically by defending his actions
you are buying into that kind of morality. That is the whole
point. How the is Destiny pretending he doesn't understand this?
What is wrong with this guy? It's so obvious, man. >> Yes.
So, you think that if you dox a person, then it is the equivalent
to dox the other person's every single unrelated family member
because the one person who got doxed might have a family member
that lives with them? >> No, that's not that's literally
not the argument at all. >> Yeah, sure. Let me go ahead
and ask you a question. But can I
just wanted to hear that I just want to hear that's >> Can
I kick you so Destiny and I can just >> I don't know. I
don't know why Connor I don't know why Connor said yes to that.
That's not what Conor's saying. He's not saying it is you you
can do that now. He's saying that Destiny if you meet a character
who is who is the same morality as you. You are by by doxing
people and by doxing the adjacent of people you don't like, you
are invoking some harm back on yourself by threatening to dox
the people around the people you dislike. Right. You are invoking
the possibility of harm. You are creating that possibility within
your own framework. It's so not >> No, no, no. I don't
have that conversation. I don't give a honestly. Um the second
question >> I give a second the second >> I give
a because I think hold on hold on hold on. If we are I know the
I know the thumbnail was a meme, but I I think that this situation
is actually quite serious and you are thinking about like complete
disassociation for me and Wick. So >> this is not a serious
conversation. I'm not I want Hang on. I'm sorry. I'm being honest.
Like that's that opinion is so immediately stupid. I'm not even
going to pretend to have a conversation with you unless
um
all the financial
stupid [__] opinion. >> Um hold on. Wait there
because there were like two other things related to Oh, [__]
>> No, wait. Wait. If you're if you just let this guy >> Conor
does not like this. Okay. Connor is not having a good time. You're
to cut me off. I'M YOUR FRIEND.
>> YOU JUST LET THIS GUY TALK un unchallenged for four
hours. Apparently, you're doing talking the same racist as my
community and now he gets to leave right away because you want
me to call him back. I'll literally CALL HIM BACK. BUT I'LL tell
you what I'm not going to do. I'll I'll literally call him back
in the next 30 seconds. I'll bring Fel on in order to ask the
exact questions what you want to ask. But what I'm not going
to do, and I'll tell you right now, is I'm not going to have
you say that after you and I have had a five going on six-year
relationship that you get to deem a topic undeserving of your
time, attention, or conversation. That's not happening. So, so
if you want to have a conversation about whether or not doxing
an individual is equivalent to doxing their family, we can have
that conversation. If you want to talk to Duby, we can TALK TO
DUBY. >> DO IT. Do it real quick. Dude, write it down.
Go ahead.
>> So, okay. So, if I get doxed, my name, phone number,
and address are located. How hard do you think it is to find
my extended family members?
>> Well, I don't know. Depends on where they live. Could
be >> [__] It's in it's sometimes it's as easy
as a white pages or yellow pages Google search. So now I have
to wonder whether or not you're because you didn't even want
to talk about this topic. Now >> like you're obviously
putting other people at risk when you dock somebody, Destiny.
Yes or no? And he's just going he's basically I don't know. I
don't know. It depends. I don't know. I don't know. It depends.
>> We're talking about it and I ask you a pretty simple
and direct question. You're saying I don't know. I think you
>> the problem. No. No. The problem Connor the reason why
this is the most topic in the world is because you're talking
about using theoretical collateral damage to make a direct target
of somebody else's family member. Do you know if any No. No.
No.
In fact, everybody says that would be
You are opening other people's families up to risk that was not
there before.
That is the wrong that you're doing. That is the that is what
you are saying is morally justified to go after somebody. And
Connor is saying, well, if you're going to open up other people's
family members to risk, you understand that you are doing the
same to your own family, right? that there will be somebody who
is the same kind of monster you are and they will operate on
that same level of principle and maybe that's just through going
after you and you know the risk is you know if your family is
around but maybe that's going after other people too because
they see the risk that you're opening them up to right like if
you were to go after let's say Dubie he's got a family he's got
a wife and kids that you if you go after him you are going after
his adjacent
you are you just are
do you understand that Somebody is going to have the same level
of belief that I should open up everybody, right? Somebody hypothetically,
not me, hypothetically, somebody will see it the same way that
I can open up your people to the same risk that you just opened
up mine to that that is the risk you are incurring when you engage
in this >> Even people that I even have family members
that live with them or even have children at all? >> No,
I don't. But at the same time, I think it's a logical >> infence.
HOLD ON. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. But Doobie is running around here
dozens of times making these arguments in these weird whatever
the six hour. Doobie has a family and you threaten to him on
all these servers arguing that my kid and >> so not dude
it's not even confusing. Dubbie has a family. Destiny threatened
to Doobie that Destiny has said multiple times, give me Dubbie's
information. I will publish it as soon as I can.
Are you out of your mind? Oh, but I didn't yet. Okay, but you
want to? Yes, he will literally admit he wants to.
He will literally admit this and then he's going, "But nobody
nobody even has a family." BRO, HOW WOULD YOU EVEN KNOW? logical
inference. >> HOLD ON. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT. BUT Doobie
is running around here dozens of times making these arguments
in these weird whatever the six hour VCs on all these servers
arguing that my kid and his mom are fair game. You crazy cotter.
>> Sure. Let's go ahead and address that. So let's say
hypothetically, well actually no, we don't even have to treat
it as a hypothetical. We could treat this as a real thing. >> Let's
talk about There you go. Yes. >> Yeah. Let's talk about
real things. So Dubbie does have a family. >> Have you
called for his docs in the
>> Oh, Connor's just got it exact. Yeah, Desi's Desi is
completely It's over. It's over. WHY DOES HE EVEN ARGUE THIS?
Does he not understand?
Does he just have no remembrance, no recollection of the things
he said and done? Is he just operating like without his brain,
without any long-term memory? Brother, what the are you talking
about? You threatened to do somebody with a family. You have
said and doubled down multiple times. If somebody gets me this
guy's information, I will publish it
Well, do whatever the six hour VCs on all these servers arguing
that my kid and his mom are fair game gambit. You
>> Sure. Let's go ahead and address that. So, let's say
hypothetically, well, actually, we don't even have to treat it
as a hypothetical. We can treat this as a real thing. >> Let's
talk about There you go. Yes. >> Yeah. Let's talk about
real things. So, Dubbie does have a family. >> Have you
called for his Excuse me. >> Dy has not been doxed.
>> Have you called for his dogs in the past? I'm pretty
sure we had a conversation about it in person. >> I'm trying
to find it. Yeah, but I don't have it. >> Okay. So if you
had found it, would you have published it?
>> Almost certainly yes.
>> He has a family.
So his argument is you don't know what's going on in people's
lives and when you expose their PII, you don't know if most of
the time it's going to be fine, but you don't know whether or
not you're going to put them in direct harm. Correct. >> I
mean, that's kind of the point of DXY. >> Dude, can you
hear my hand hit my forehead? Can you hear my hand hit my forehead
when he does this?
Yeah. Yeah. That's kind of like the point. I want them to feel
threatened.
>> Yeah. No.
>> Right. So, if Dubie was, we're not even engaging in
hypotheticals. We're engaging in a real example. So, if you had
Docs Doobie, let's say you just found his PII, you publish it
to the internet. And let's say that he is the internet vigilante
that he claims to be and then Adam off and finds his house and
kills him and his family. Aren't you partially responsible for
that behavior? >> You possibly could be, but you think,
dude, what?
>> You possibly maybe could be hypothetic.
you would be partially respons responsible. What your part is
like nobody's arguing that it's like okay to go after you but
you've created an attenuated risk. Somebody could create that
same attenuated risk back on you or your family. That is that
is the thing you're signing up for
ask.
You don't have to talk to me about this. This has been my life
for the last year. You Okay, hold on. So, shut the up. Let's
say that I were to find uh Doobie's information and then I found
the information of his kid and I started posting his. Do you
think that's the same thing? No. Thank you. Then you agree with
me. Then move on to another topic. This is No.
LET'S GO, CONNOR.
JUST MOVE ON TO another topic. I know I totally wrecked on this
one. No. No. How about No. How about we keep talking about this
one where you're being a total psychopath? >> I won't because
it's quite clear. So let's say let's say that you had posted
his PII and then he'd gotten and his dogs had gotten shot or
his kids had gotten injured in the thing. You're partially responsible.
Yeah.
>> And then
Conor Conor,
>> you are signing up for at minimum the same attenuated
risk and that is assuming that you haven't you've basically done
a like a stepwise you've jumped to a different level of escalation
entirely. You're hoping that you don't have other people around
you that will jump to a higher escalation too, right? But you
you are opening up everybody around you to the same attenuated
risk, the same level of conduct back towards you and the people
around you. Yes, that's what you're >> It's still not the
same as boasting his
>> I don't think that's even the argument that he made.
>> That is the argument he's saying that my it is okay
to a log my minor child and that it would be fine to post my
clip or you have somebody that could give me >> He didn't
say this at all. By the way, all of this is wrong. Like Destiny
is totally skipping the part where we all think he is an immoral
psychopath, right? Literally, everybody thinks you're an immoral
psychopath. We're we're just explaining to you the risk you're
opening up you and your loved ones to. That's we're explaining
the risk you're signing up for, not what we think should happen.
We all think you're an immoral psychopath who is like crashing
the out. That's what's going on here, Destiny. We all think you're
losing your mind. Do you understand? Do you even remotely understand
what's going on? clip. >> Bring him in here. He'll argue
it.
>> I don't think Doobie is going to argue it, guys. I'm
pretty sure Doobie is not going to argue. >> We understand
because seriously, some DG Chatters were some of the dumbest
who >> DG Chatters or DG Conor.
>> I told you he's going to be I told you we went through
that whole thing before cuz he's going to see about Connor saying
maybe Connor said before maybe DGers are Indians. Maybe English
is their second language. Maybe they just don't get it. And Pest
is like seeing snarkers everywhere. He's seeing snarkers everywhere.
Is it DG or Connor? >> I'm not anti-Indian.
>> Okay. Butter butter chicken.
>> Are you with us? >> I'm here. Dude, did you say
that it was acceptable to a log my son and use and save the information
until he's an adult to send it to somebody later on and the goal
of getting him fired from a job or kicked out of school? >> No,
I said the opposite. >> What did you say? >> Okay,
so I'll just lay it out for you, right? You can tell me why you
disagree with us. >> You got you got to make him answer
faster, bro. I don't because he's going to say >> it's
descriptive. Steven, you used to be the master.
Don't tell me to force him to answer the question and then tell
me to shut up. That doesn't make sense. >> I'm losing my
mind. It's all good. Don't worry. I just woke up for my dude.
>> You don't have anything else to do. Are you going to
go a chick? >> I have a million other things to do. And
up and begging a tick would be infinitely more entertaining than
listening to the same guy that was slobbering and crying about
food trucks being hosted by my stream at night. Make justification
why guys who are spending hours every day. WHY THEY DO MY [__]
SLEEP? WHY they should BE ALLOWED
STEVEN? THAT'S A NORMAL OPINION. IT'S A NORMAL OPINION.
>> Oh my god. This guy's being mentally abused by your
ass and he's crashing out now. No way.
>> Mentally abused.
>> This guy's This guy's like said he he's tried to dox
me. He's like advocated for my death. By the way, just as like
another thing. And I would never say he can't do this. I would
never say you have to like ban him from the internet for it.
But he also thought he found like my dad's obituary and laughed
at me for my dad dying of cancer
because he thought that happened. It's like like I don't I I'm
sorry if I were doing this. If that's all I was doing,
you wouldn't really be able to call me out while being a fan
of his and up and begging would be infinitely more entertaining
than listening to the same guy that was slobbering and crying
about food shops being hosted by my stream at night. They justification
why guys who are spending hours every day.
WHY THEY ALLOW PEOPLE?
THAT'S a normal opinion. It's >> you don't even LIKE FOOD
SHOPS. LIKE my now. Like my friend now, Connor. Why would you
like my friend? It's so up. Just like my FRIEND NOW.
>> DO NOT WANT to hang OUT WITH HERE. I DON'T HANG OUT
WITH THESE PEOPLE AND DIES HERE BEGGING GIRLS. >> You hang
out with food shops ALL THE TIME. WHAT >> girls and DMs
FOR SIX YEARS. >> Let him do the next one. You what? You
hung out with Doobie the same as me for six years. Just don't
tell me you don't hang out with these.
That's a lie. I'm not a pedoph.
The entire goddamn panel scene where I met you too, by the way.
>> Out of here. >> I'm sorry. Are we saying hang
out is when on panels together? In that case, fine. I guess I
hang out with Vivian. >> Friendship was based off of panels
for the first three years of our friendship. you. So yeah, don't
get all dismissive about the
everything you're saying is the most you think that the friendship
that we have right now is THE SAME. >> NO, IT'S NOT. YOU'RE
JUST pissed off and you know a BUNCH OF SICK FANS GOING TO YOU
OFF and I'm not going to do it. >> Sick of my sick offense.
You're so how many dy I'm curious dy if YOU HAD TO GUESS HOW
MANY SIDES SPLINTER DISCORDS can open right now that are cheering
on Connor for standing up to the evil horrible terrible destiny.
How many open right now? >> Stand up. Yeah, you're acting
like a total tyrant right now. Yeah, there are people who are
laughing at Connor standing up to you because you are acting
like a petty, childish tyrant. You're a loser. Yes, lots of people
are laughing at you. Act like a complete loser.
Yeah, obviously, dude. Are you serious? Are you serious?
How many people are like laughing at my crash out right now?
Lots. Like a whole lot. Like a ton of people are laughing at
your crash out explicitly right now. I to I don't know what else
to tell you, man. I'm not I'm not going to pretend otherwise.
I laughed at this. I watched this whole thing. I watched this
scene earlier today and laughed about it in my Discord and now
I'm watching it on stream. This is my second run through and
it's still funny. So, I know Die, go ahead and justify why you
can a log my 15-year-old kid. Go. >> Yes, please. >> Okay,
so I'll lay it out for you again like I to Connor. So, there
are lots of crazy people online. When you encourage doxing of
other people in the space, you don't know what the who who you're
talking to, right? There could be some lunatic in your community
that sees me and thinks that sees me, think, believes everything
they say about me, thinks that I'm trying to take you down and
thinks it's justified to attack me physically, to attack my family
physically. There could be people that I have unrelated uh beef
with, right? And I do that might say, "Hey, do we have address
now? Let's go." So, I'm not saying that you personally would
be uh my son, but you me, given that I live with my son, would
put my entire family at risk. That is just a reality. I'm not
saying it's a good thing. I don't accept it. I would not do that
to you or your son ever. I would never support that ever. What
I'm telling you is you need to stop creating this environment.
>> Yes. The best way to explain this is you are an amoral
psycho creating a world that you deserve and we all want you
to stop cuz we're getting caught in the crossfire. You're a totally
unprincipled amoral psycho. Please stop. Please just even if
you are even if you are this way, just stop advertising it and
forcing everybody else to get caught in the crossfire here. That's
all you got to do. LIKE TAKE ONE STEP BACK and stop being a total
piece of >> where that's going to be normalized.
>> Just curious, Connor, did you hear an explanation there
or is that >> I did and I've been linked clips where people
have said his description like what he's saying right now is
a lie and then when I get linked the clips he's saying the exact
same thing.
>> If you want to show him being a liar, give me the clip.
I would love it. >> What he has said is that right now
based on the rules that I've created, a logging my child would
be fair game. Right. Die. >> Correct. Because you put his
child at
>> Okay. So, the more these are morally equivalent actions
in your eyes is a 15-year-old child until they're 18 to burn
in whatever you managed to collect to their future employer,
whatever. That is the morally equivalent. They're they're well,
I wouldn't say those are morally equivalent. I'm sure Duby would
feel they're morally equivalent if you doxed him,
right? But they're not. They're not necessarily morally equivalent.
It's that you are creating that thing. You are creating an attenuated
risk. And one, when you create that risk, when you do that jump
in escalation to a new tier of behavior, you are hoping that
everybody else sees the attenuated risk you see and only goes
as far as you think you you went. But they might not see it that
way. You're opening them up to totally crazy from people who
don't have a solid head on their shoulders, right? In a way they
weren't opened up before.
And that you're opening Pandora's box. So stop for the sake of
everybody. Stop action. Stop posting the name and address of
somebody and then maybe having family members live with them.
These are two things are morally equivalent to you. >> If
you are risking his child of homicide,
why wouldn't he be allowed to a log in your child? >> Okay.
So then just to be clear,
I AGREE WITH YOU. I AGREE WITH YOU. NO. OKAY. I agree with you.
It's fair game right now. If I find the of any of Doobie's family
members, it's fair game for me to post them, right? >> Has
he you? >> No. But he's made the argument that's fair game
to go for Wait. No. Oh my god. Destiny. Destiny, very important
question. If you see the any clip from day from today, answer
this one question. How would you feel
if you didn't have breakfast this morning? Destiny. Destiny.
Destiny.
We need to make sure that we could still answer this question.
Are you capable? Do you have the head on your shoulders to answer
this question still? I'm not convinced,
bro. >> For my family, so I should be able >> descriptive
or prescriptive. >> I'm being descriptive. I'm just saying
it would be right. Like he wouldn't be able to complain about
it. defectively. Hold on. I know.
>> I know you know this, which is why this conversation
is so frustrating.
>> I'm describing
because you No, no. You've talked about tit for tat. You've talked
about eye for an eye. >> I'm describing right now, Conor.
I'm only describing.
>> Excuse me. >> I'm only describing. >> I
didn't say I would do it. I didn't say I should do it. I'm just
saying that if I did, you wouldn't be able to complain about
it. >> You don't think that's a substantive
>> I never said I should do it. I'm just saying he wouldn't
be able to complain about it. Like, I could do it and I would
have justification for that. I don't think I should. So, hold
on. Hold on. Let's just agree. Stop talking. >> Oh my god.
>> So, if Doobie doxed you first and he put your child
at risk, >> I'm just I'm just describing. I'm just describing.
Dude, the the tactics are so bad when they're like removed from
the clapping seals. The tactics are >> Based off of an
eye for an eye morality,
>> you would be entitled to doxing his family and putting
his family at risk. That's descriptively true. where the description
that Doobie was making, the description that Dubbie was making
was that some crazy person might find it to do something horrible
to his family and blah blah blah blah blah. My argument would
be some crazy person, and by crazy person, I mean the people
that are alreadying
harassing me and calling on my family members, they might see
Duby's argument and go, "Oh, Duby's actually spitting fire here.
We should actually try to family." I have way more evidence on
my side for this.
>> So, Destiny acting like a total psychopath and basically
taunting his own Kiwi Farms thread is everybody else's problem.
And when you criticize him, when you point out that he's doing
harmful behaviors, when you point out that he's hurt a bunch
of people and has never taken accountability or responsibility
for his harmful actions, that is apparently endorsing those people's
actions. Apparently, that's like what he's trying to convince
you that because he won't stop taunting total schizophrenics
on the internet
that now nobody could criticize him. They're actually going to
do harm to him by criticizing him, by using speech. Cool. Cool.
Cool. Cool. That's fine. What's the next
describe something inaccurately declare victory and walk away?
>> That's not what you mean. >> What am I describing?
Dubie is making a description. You're justify
this directly. Answer this directly. I want you to answer this
directly. >> Yeah. If if Doobie doxed you and put your
child at risk, would you not be descriptively entitled to doxing
him and putting his children at risk? >> The goal of doxing
without putting their children. If that happens, it's collateral.
If somebody dox them, yeah, >> Don't Okay. So, the answer
is yes.
>> And so, you put his family at risk. So descriptively,
he's saying, "You are creating a world in which it is okay for
him to do the same to you, but he's not going to. He doesn't
have to. He's out here in Discords doing the equivalent of calling
for it." When you're out here saying Destiny wouldn't be able
to complain if people doxed his whole family because he's created
the world for it and that's the world we live in now. That's
the argument he's making. if he's going to say that there's a
chance that a crazy um by the way this is the same argumentation
they have to use against Hassan on some of the like left like
left-leaning pipeline stuff some of the extremist stuff they
do the same thing Connor will engage in the same behavior with
Hassan and he's not willing to call it out there like he will
do the same thing when Hassan describes how hey actually like
if people come and watch my stream and they end up going to you
guys like by by advocating for the same policies we actually
help both of our movements at the same time he's describing something
That is
that is something he's describing. He's not describing really
wanting to get people down into like Marxist Leninist pipeline.
He probably thinks he's got a better way with like some revisionist
Marxism. He probably thinks he's got some better way to go, but
he doesn't say that. >> Why is it not the same on his side
when people have done this to my family?
>> Okay, so hold on. Let's go ahead and follow that. So
based off of that, you're saying that he's creating the stochastic
permission structure through which you can be doxed and harassed.
And since you're being doxed and harassed, you have the right
to dox him. No, hold on. I don't care about me being doctor.
You're proving here. I barely human you guys anyway. I don't
care about me. What I'm saying?
You saying that your friends don't just let you do whatever the
you want. They call you out when you're doing something >> Call
me out. Oh my god, you guys are so entitled. It actually drives
me insane. But that's fine.
>> What? What?
Okay, that's crazy. Yeah, CALL ME OUT. YOU'RE SO ENTITLED.
Uh he just literally wants the best for you. He's literally just
trying to tell you that you're like things up right now. You're
having a crash out. You are manic. Chill the out, man. You just
got to chill the out. You're You're in a total manic state right
now. It's [__] up.
man. Uh
I'm I feel bad for Connor cuz Connor's saying the right things.
I wish I wish Jesse had more friends like Connor. Okay. And I
also wish that they would have stood with the spine Connor standing
with now a year ago.
All of this could have been avoided if everybody stood on business
and said, "Hey, you're doxing people for no reason. Can you show
me evidence for that?" No. Oh, well, I'm not going to interact
with you ever again unless you do that. So, like, cop, you're
you're literally splitting away from everybody who likes you
and is is close to you. If only. If only.
But nobody did it. Everybody supported it. Everybody still hung
around. total.
All of this is because he didn't have people who would stand
there and tell him like, "No, I won't be around you if you're
going to do this." >> Literally nobody. >> I'm sorry.
I'm sorry. I think you're doing something cringe and gay. And
I'm I'm I'm entitled because I'm saying you're doing something
cringe and gay. >> Yeah. Yes. >> Oh, you. So, YOU
DO WANT TO tongue up your ass. >> So, my Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Oh, dude. Conor's actually spitting today. He picked it out immediately.
I'm entitled because I'm pointing out your bad behavior. Yes.
Uh-huh.
That's his homeland. >> Yeah, dude. That's me. You totally
figured it out, bro. Um, not not not the guy that's in here donating
what was it, $10,000 to streamers for the past 18 months to try
to hold on friendships so they go into Discords and talk about
me
for a year. Not that guy. I'm the one who wants the special treatment.
Wasn't your mod just in here earlier telling you that people
like Duby were cancer? Maybe he wants to tongue up his ass, too.
Who's that stuck up loser? What was his name? Fels. What' you
call him? >> The the mod who was just totally taking Destiny's
side. Dest said he just woke up, but he was listening to the
argument with the mod.
H be mean to fail runner. Fellr runner likes you. >> I
don't know who else puts a tongue up their ass. We don't want
people that are gossiping, calling the and taking part actively
in communities that have been doxing, swatting, making bomb threats
with his family for the past two years. I don't know who else
is like a spoiled like that. >> Okay. Okay. My question
[__] >> Go ahead. >> My simple question
is is how is Doobie running around all these VCs making the argument
that well according to Destiny it should be okay to a log his
family members and them. How is that not also creating an environment
where crazies can, you know, find or think that they have some
justification in doing this? Because if you actually watch the
clips in their entirety, immediately after he gets done saying
that in descriptive nature, he says, "I wish everybody would
stop doing this so we could return to what Twitch and YouTube
politics was 2 years ago where doxing was not something that
we would tolerate. It was a taboo." >> Which side do you
think contributes to it, Connor?
>> Which side do I think contributes to the normalization
of doxing and harassment? Let me let me ask. >> Dude, you
don't want Why would you ask that question? You don't want to
know the answer to that question. >> This question. If
I were to drop all of my aggression towards this these communities,
do you think that they would still continue to dox, swat, harass,
inject themselves into my life in as many ways as possible? >> If
you don't take responsibility and accountability for the things
you've done wrong, then no, we'll still point out the things
you've done wrong. Will we be as aggressive about it? I don't
know. It would depend on what you took accountability for, what
you took responsibility for, right? what you made amends for.
But if you are just going to keep crashing out and threatening
everybody around you, well, no, we're not going to stop.
Dude, I've already said this multiple times. If this guy could
just admit his wrongdoing, apologize to the people he's done
it to, try to make amends, I I wouldn't like it cuz I I think
he's like he'sed up my life in some ways. Okay. But I would let
it go. I would feel compelled to let it go if he truly tried
to turn over another leaf. But I I've never se I've never seen
any propensity for that from him whatsoever. I've never seen
any indication that that's something that would even cross his
mind. And again, the I've said this repeatedly through all of
the Destiny stuff, including Dan going on a stream and calling
me a repeatedly.
The solution to this, the response to this is just content. I
will keep making content on these crashes. I will keep documenting
this. I will always be here to respond.
And if you want to actually escalate this to a place where I
can't, that'll require drastic action on your
But the response is never to dox, to harass, to do anything in
real life. It is just to document and respond. Document and respond.
Document and
And eventually we win.
That's the solution. That's what we're doing. That's how we win.
>> I think yes. >> Okay. And if they were to stop,
do you think that I would be for months, years after be like,
"Guys, we still got to go after we got to get this guy. We got
to fuck." Do you think that I would continue on? No. If they
were to stop, okay, so it's them. I don't know why you're making
this a both sides thing. Again, if he wants to attach this to
Kiwi Farms, which he always does, right? The Kiwi Farm stuff
was in full swing before any of the got leaked that made me dislike
this person, that made me want to do content negatively about
this person. Okay. All the Kiwi Farms harassment against him
and against the people around him was in full swing before Queen
or me got involved at all. Before anybody got involved at all,
>> that's not my fault. You cannot blame me for that. It's
them. You understand? >> Because I can articulate this
because you are engaged in total warfare. You are going scorched
earth. If we were to analogize this to Vietnam, you are dropping
Napom. You're burning thatched houses. You're executing civilians
who are sympathetic to Viet. >> Hold on. What is the most
scorched earth thing that I've done? >> Sports Batman.
And >> I wish I lived I wish I could live for >> I
wish I wish I lived in a world where that was like the scorched
earth because holy that sounds like heaven to me. >> I
can't believe
>> this guy legitimately thinks that because he gets like
punched in the face, he's allowed to like slap somebody random
and unrelated.
like not even unrelated, just somebody who like shares the same
political affiliation or something. But it's like there's a behavior
happening to you that I disagree with. Like Destiny has had people
like the cops show up to his place, right?
I could disagree with those behaviors like people trying to invoke
some sort of real world harm or trying to swat him, trying to
dox people around him. I disavow all of that. But that doesn't
mean like that the fact that that happens to you is not a reason
that you can go after me in some similar fashion, right? It's
It's wild. I just don't get it. I I'm not talking about morally
justified. I'm just saying that your portrayal of this is scorched
earth. When I have a community of people who are weaponizing
mentally ill women to try to destroy my life in court, you're
like the worst THING EVER. DESTINY, YOU'RE GOING SCORCHED EARTH
CUZ YOU a few of the most active members OF THESE COMMUNITIES.
DESTINY SCORCH. By the way, just not even the most active members.
You just you like literally with e with esports Batman and Supreme.
I feel like it's just because they were people he like had as
active parts of his community before.
I I actually don't think it has to do with how active they were.
I think they were in his community and he thinks it's a betrayal
and that's why he went after them. What has happened to any of
these people? Has anything have anybody been swatted? Has anybody
shown up at any other places work? Has anybody sued any of these
people? Has anything happened to any of these people? >> Uh
here's here's one person who's saying, "Yeah, this did happen
to me."
This is one person who you have
who you part who you've participated in harassment campaigns
against. By the way, I've also like I watched the Anavore streams.
I feel guilt for that. Like when I when I see the system I participated
in, right? I watched the Anavore streams. I thought that was
funny. It was psychotic.
Okay. I just didn't I didn't step back and understand what was
going on. And now I do see it. It's like, dude, it's it's actually
pretty crazy. >> I'll ask you a question. Was it moral
or just to do what you did? >> Yeah, I would say so. Yeah.
Self-defense and accountability. >> If doesn't like the
idea, if the idea doesn't like the idea that him running around
saying insane about me 24/7 all this time, if he thinks that
his real life name being attached to that would make him act
significantly different, maybe he should reconsider the things
that he says or does. The reason why when I post stuff, I post
it on my name in my chat under my account IS BECAUSE I WILL TAKE
ACCOUNTABILITY for the things that I say. Easy. Full stop. You
know my full name. You know my address because Pixie loves to
over it every two weeks at a court filing. So if you want to
talk to me or do anything to me, YOU CAN SHUT MY CAR. BUT LORD
DELA gave you the Florida to take the elevator up on. Meanwhile,
Dubie wants to run around and talk the weirdest about me 247
over his mountains of child that he claims he's hoarding for
the FBI. He was me every single day. He's like, "Well, I do."
That is not true. Doobie is a good
I'm not going to say I'm a good person, but I'm certainly nothing
like Destiny. Okay?
They want to make it the same because they want to normalize
his disgusting behavior.
We will not let that happen. No thank you. No thank you. You're
gross. We don't want to be like you. Don't make us the same.
We are not the same. >> Do this honestly. Nobody should
know. And if people even knew my name, they would come to my
family. Maybe that's an indictment on his behavior more than
>> Okay. So to be So let let's go for wicked. So let's
ignore Doobie for a second. Esports Batman gave legal consultation
to Jtock, one of your principled haters in the nexus of your
whatever you want to call it, your f your haters, your snarkers.
So, in your mind, doxing him was justified.
>> When you say legal console, what do you
>> Was wasn't uh his crime or alleged crime giving legalistic
feedback to JTO in reference to your court case? >> Essports
Batman credentials himself as a lawyer and is literally creating
a permission structure in their discord for a way through which
they can misinterpret or whatever interpret, however you want
to call it, every court filing I have. He's like their he's like
their on call legal guy. Anytime you hear Dubbie or any other,
like, oh, lawyers told me this, they're talking about esports
Batman. I think if you're going to put YOUR CREDENTIALS OUT THERE,
IF YOU'RE PUTTING if you're if somebody thinks that I think that
Kofka coming on is a legal person or just stream and this is
who he is or whatever. I mean, yeah. I mean, I think that I think
it's fair. There's a reason why, by the way, most leaguers most
lawyers are really reluctant to show up and like give a whole
bunch of legal advice or go give a whole bunch of stuff on [__]
streams or YouTube because when you cancel yourself, that's kind
of a thing. I well I I think Destiny is more comparing somebody
like um like his former friend who'd be a lawyer who works at
like who who could potentially work at like a big law firm or
want a future in politics. People who like have a very pristine
like a need for a pristine future, they might really avoid that.
Some people are like smaller town lawyers and they have like
a law firm they work at or maybe a law firm that they're even
a partner in, but realistically like something like internet
drama isn't going to with them like Nick Rakita, right? Nick
Rakita could have been a lawyer and stayed a lawyer and done
his little local law practice and really all the internet drama
wouldn't have probably with that that much.
It's like unless they're doing something improper, in which case
if they're doing something improper, the solution isn't to dox
them. The solution would be to do something else, right? It would
be to like report them to an authority if you thought they were
doing something improper
if that's what you thought. But obviously that's not what Destiny
thought cuz Destiny didn't go to anybody. He just just wants
to harass people away from commenting the sick. I will say there's
a substantial difference between Kafka uh coming on and talking
about like random Supreme Court ruling and esports Batman being
the personal on call snarker lawyer to give all the interpretations
of all the legal and the same service where people are reaching
out to and harassing witnesses in my case. I think those are
substantially different
I'm going someplace. So So HFA has talked about your court case
on stream,
>> Okay. So since he's giving you feedback in reference
to your case the exact same Connor. Yes. You're a genius. Yes.
So he should he should be right because he's enabling the internet
machine.
>> If I found out that Kofka was in a server where they
were trying to reach >> I don't want you to change it.
I want you to answer the question. >> I'm not changing.
I'm making it one to one. I'm not watering it down like your
dumbass just did. If Kofa was >> I need I need to give
YOU ALL THE HOLD ON. I NEED TO I NEED TO FRAME everything so
that I'm the perpetual victim. Actually helping Pixie in any
way is evil. And as long as you think that and when I when I
wanted to reach out and get Rose as a part of the case, that
was totally moral. And they are like forcing a victim at gunpoint
to testify. It's soed up. Wait, Destiny, how did they learn that
she was like a victim of trafficking? Oh, through the deposition.
Oh, so time flows one way and there was nothing wrong with that.
Okay, cool. >> In a Discord server where people were reaching
out to and harassing uh family and friends of of JTO or trying
to harass witnesses to bring the case and Cockas in the back
say like, "Oh, look at these legal fun. Yeah, I think you know
this is actually fine. I think actually this is totally purposeful."
Blah blah. >> Show evidence of people harassing your family.
What the I'm the king of and find out when the have I ever looked
at a situation like that and be like I can't believe this guy
did this thing [__] recorded. Of course, I would
understand it. But for you to compare Kafka coming onto my public
stream and like talking sometimes and now more towards the end
of the beginning about court filings that's the same as esports
Batman who exists in a server where they are reaching out to
and harassing [__] witnesses in my case and he's
sitting there creating the permission structure for by credentiing
himself a lawyer and then giving [__] >> Destiny
has harassed actively witnesses in his case. Just to be clear,
like Destiny has harassed witnesses in his case. Absolutely.
He has >> feedback on everybody. You But I know in your
mind you're going to find a way to make that equivalent. That's
fine.
>> Uh well, okay. So, so hold on. So, you've acknowledged
descriptively while adding 10,000 qualifiers that CFKA is coming
on in order to >> Wait, hold on. Wait, real quick. You
can acknowledge this real quick. All the 10
qualifiers haven't even been litigated. They're just your narrativization
of events.
lay out how your arguments follow from the logs you show.
He knows he can't do it. He knows that when he goes to try to
lay out this narrative that he's painting of like everybody's
celebrating because like family members were contacted or something.
When he lays this out chronologically, he knows he can't support
the things he's saying. He knows he's and he's spiraling because
of it. >> All the ones that apply to esports Batman, right?
>> That okay. that he lives in a discord server where people
are harassing witnesses in my case and then he's giving legal
cyber there, right?
>> Okay. I I don't want to go down this because then I
have to bring up your equivalent and then you have to tell me
how it's not equivalent. >> So So
equivalent? >> Wouldn't Wouldn't it be attempting to
>> Yes. Connor. Connor. Now ask him. Ask him why he talks
bros >> after your homemade.
>> I'll articulate. You said what with an exclamation point
and a question mark. I would like the opportunity to explain.
>> I know. I understand what you're saying. I just have
to catch up on I don't know how mind you you are by the in your
DMs. Okay. So I understand what you're saying >> My question
IS YOU THINK YOU ARE fully
>> you're fully you are. I'm sorry. So let me just I I
know exactly what you're saying. You're saying that Rose, right?
WHY DID I WHY DID I want to find out who Rose was? because she
leaked her homemade to the internet. >> Do you think it's
fair for me to want to know who that person is?
>> Do you think that that is at all equivalent to them
reaching out and harassing a person because they're trying to
out of Don't you think it's relevant to get her testimony on
the record for the case? You did before.
How did you learn that she was like a that she was blackmailed
into doing all of this stuff? That's the claim she made, right?
Where did she make that claim? How did you learn that?
>> Okay, hold on. We're we're going to do an experiment
in empathy and you need to slow down a little bit. Okay. Do you
think that people could earnestly hate you for the way that you've
conducted yourself on the internet for the past 3 to 5 years?
>> That has nothing to do with this. I'm not answering.
>> That's a totally irrelevant question, dude. Come on.
>> What the does that have to do with what we're talking
about here? Because it's the motivations of the people. It's
the motivations of the people that you're talking about. >> No,
I would say no. Connor, no. There is no reason. No. Give me one.
Name a single bad thing I've done on the internet in the past
5 years, Connor.
I infamously I am a kind and caring and compassionate person.
Infamously so. >> Sorry. You fat. TELL ME WHAT. GIVE ME
ONE REASON. >> CALL ME A FAT. YOU HAVEN'T LIFTED a weight
in five goddamn years. You piece of Shut the [__]
>> Tell me. I wouldn't be able to withstand the pressure.
Conor, tell me right now. WHAT IS WHAT IS ONE VALID REASON why
these people could hate me for my behavior the past 5 years?
Tell me. >> Well, hold on. Do you I'll give you the general
reasons for why people hate you. I know. NUMBER ONE. NO. NO.
YOU ASK. I'M going to answer. You ask, I'm going to answer. You
ask, I'm going to answer. So, how about how about that time?
How about that time that you posted uh a Minecraft uh character
destroying a holy site in Islam? Do you think you got a FEW TESTS
FROM THAT? >> NO MUSLIM. THAT WOULD EXPLAIN SO MUCH. DON'T
ISOLATE. Don't isolate. I'm ask I asked you a question. Don't
isolate. I asked you a question. Do you think that people could
earnestly hate you? If you already know your chronology of sins,
then you already know there's 10,000 reasons why people could
earnestly hate you. and wants you dead. >> None of that
has anything to do with this situation at all. >> So, so
hold on. You think JTock, Queenman, Esports Batman, they all
hate you for delusional or non-serious
>> Uh I Okay, >> that's crazy. >> Okay, dude.
>> That's why when I asked you for one, the only thing
you can name is the Cabba
>> You know, you don't think that you're come up with a
dozen reasons to hate you OFF THE TOP OF MY HEAD. >> GIVE
ME ONE. GIVE ME ONE FROM their perspective. Go. I mean, you're
just like a liar. You're literally just a lying scumbag.
You people. You dropped all your principles. You don't actually
believe in attribution of like attribution of blame in terms
of communities on the internet. Right. The entire CEO's manifesto
was a lie.
What else? Uh, you totally misrepresented and lied about the
Anavar situation and manipulated her into taking your side so
that Mr. Girl wouldn't with you. Um, you ruined Mr. Girl's career
over him basically soul raiding you. There's probably a lot more.
Like if I could think about it, these would all be reasons to
dislike Destiny before even getting to the leaks from January.
>> WELL, THEY THINK THAT YOU USE YOUR SEXUAL POWER AND
clout and influence and money in order to mentally women. Give
me what example. Annavore.
Annavore reached out to me. Anavore wanted to meet me for two
or three years. Is she more or less than Cherry?
Cherry's also
one time, by the way. How the [__] I I don't want
to hear this person reference
>> How could there be any hatred of me when I hooked up
to this girl one time, by the way, when she pursued me over and
over and over and over and over over again? By the way, when
there's not a single example of me leveraging more power dynamics
to do anything to her, by the way, >> do you or do you
not think that people could rightfully criticize you for repeatedly
engaging with mentally ill
Repeatedly engaging with mentally ill women. If your first go-to
example is Anavoir, I just want to tell you in the real world,
I know you've been mind by this online. Apparently, I'm the only
one that's touched grass before. Nobody would give a about a
30-year-old woman up with a 32year-old guy who goes online to
talk about him obsessively for the next year and say, "Wow, that
guy is a I guess a horrible evil person." >> So the answer
is no.
You you actually you just like So you actually don't think it's
a valid criticism to say Steven has used money, power, clout,
and influence in order to routinely engage in promiscuous behavior
with mentally ill women. >> No, it's Dude, it's not even
If you believe if you I believe that you are mind. Okay, that's
fine. Connor, I believe. No, I believe this is
>> like why is Destiny asking like this is weird for Connor
to say? Connor has said this for the past two years like consistently
the same maybe more consistently. That's been his argument for
the past two or three years consistently with the Anavore stuff.
Is that a fair is that a fair assessment or recollection of the
Anavore stuff? A 32-y old man met up with a 30-year-old woman.
They had sex one time and then the other person, the woman, obsessed
about the man for a year. Is that all it is? I don't think that's
fair at all. You totally left out the part where you called her
a stalker to your audience and then you started with her again
and then you basically were saying, "Well, listen, I'll I'll
fix the stalker memes later and and we're still engaging in this
dynamic while your whole community was calling her stalker and
saying you'd fix it later." And then I believe after this when
she wanted to prove that she wasn't a stalker and that you were
to you were talking in the background, you threatened to leak
her nudes if she leaked your to show that you guys were still
together.
I believe that's the timeline and it's psychotic. Now if I got
the timeline off there, it is barely off at all. Okay, that like
you engaged with her while people were harassing her, while people
were calling her a stalker, and you knew how that made her spiral,
and you didn't care.
That is a that is a crazy situation. And then, by the way, to
cap it all off, you also put her Kiwi Farms thread and directed
people to her to it in your public chat like with thousands of
people in it. >> I final
since I've known you. >> You can believe that. That's fine.
Are there any other things you want to go over? Cuz this is this
is probably done.
>> Okay. Well, no. If you if you got to go, dude, I'm not
doing this thing. I'm not doing this thing where you pretend.
Yeah. See, this is so [__] we got to talk. No, no,
no. This is gay. And DG, take this clip. Take it back to your
dad. He wants to go off and watch video games. He wants to go
halfass watch.
He
It's not the best rant, but it's like Conor's got an A for effort
here, okay? It's not the It's not He's not talking the best,
but it's like an A for effort right now. Okay, we love We love
Conor. >> He wants to go half ass do tepid commentary.
Get the out of here. He doesn't have anything better to do. He
has nothing better to do. Get the out of
That that was that was the weakest
that was the weakest that's ever happened. >> So, we'll
go over to the Russell search logs here. Okay, we read through
some of these. Just a heads up, I do not support anyone going
after Conor's family, but since Connor is defending people who
are making arguments about going after against against my act
on that, uh if someone did go after Connor's family, I think
they could see that as fully justified. By the way, that's not
true. He's literally saying it's wrong. He's not advocating for
it, but Destiny just doesn't get it. Des refuses to get it. The
content changes. >> Guys, Stardust, am I known? >> I
got limited time. So, Stardust wants to come in. I want her to
say whatever she wants to say. Does Destiny want to come in or
is he just talking [__] in your DM? >> I don't
know. Okay, Destiny. Um, >> yeah. Why are you dying a few
nights ago that Wick was doxed in that server by somebody posting
his >> Wick? You can verify this. >> By the way,
can you check your DMs and verify what I just said? Does it look
like I'm lying about the characterization of those? >> Uh,
give me a second.
Uh, yeah. Yeah, you said most of the claims in that stream were
>> uh I don't think any of these people are or whatever.
Um uh I'm in that Snark left server. It's absolutely not a singing
server. Um read them out loud, but yeah. Yeah. Now this guy's
but yeah. So you were What are you talking about? >> I
just I just repeated all that when I was there. I didn't say
any of that >> This is I wouldn't be shocked if this was
um from Dan. Dan was like reaching out to a bunch of people he
knew was in the ser were in the server >> and when you
guys made the shock I DM
didn't I didn't
the moment that they said this. >> Okay. So that last message
is that one user was banned. It was from the PV filing last September
that Hassan showed on stream where people isn't that what you
said to me. Was that what was posted in that? >> That's
my That's my understanding. Yes. And I told No, what I saw was
not the PV docs. I want >> Oh, I don't know. So So again,
I saw
it from there. >> I'm I'm still upset that you called me
[__] fat even though you don't lift weights. I'm
still upset about that. >> So again, I assume So I have
the same image. I know that it was like I know what your shirt
was. I don't know if I'm going to say that, but I haven't se
I haven't seen any of it, right? Like but you but you can verify
that when they look like you're defending it. >> Hold on.
What I was defending is what I've seen. Hold on. So Destiny,
can you tell me right now? Destiny, can you tell me right? >> I've
seen it. I'm not sure how different it is from the uh the PV
stuff. It is different, but I'm not sure how >> now that
nobody has ever posted in your >> I wouldn't defend it
if I if somebody had no what I was defending is what I've seen
in the server and what I've seen allowed in the server. I have
not seen this allowed in the server. It is not a doxing server.
It is a flipping server. So it's true that about a year ago someone
posted something. I don't agree with that. >> Keep filibustering.
>> You're okay. You're interrupting me. I'm trying to [__]
respond. Let me respond and then you can go. It's fine. Keep
going. Go ahead. >> Okay. Wait. Just to be clear. Just
what?
>> Can we go one at a time? Stop. You brought the name.
Start with the Destiny is correct that what you said in those
things was incorrect. It was wrong. It was wrong. Now, I will
agree with Dubbie when it happened on stream. Doobie did DM me
and says, "I would never dox you. If you want me to if you show
me it, I will find the people who did it and get it removed and
all that." And look, I understand even you wick. I love you.
I know you're all mind raped. And I blame myself for this lark.
Okay, but Dy, I'm sorry. Wick, you understand that when he says
that, he's just trying to
Dude, this guy just can't stop watching. You can just tell the
only thing he ever watches is my stream. See you later, Koko.
Bye. >> He just watches my stream all the time. He just
said he just started saying all the things I say all the time.
>> Very, very, right?
Wait, if you tell me exactly where that came from, you see how
all these guys the whole time saying that I am much more likely
to believe you because you told me the truth and Dub lied to
me. I will say when Dub says that they're just trying to find
the leak.
Dub for the lie that Dub is trying to spin right now in person.
And again, the reason why most of these won't talk to me is because
they can't spin these lies in person because they're lying so
much. What Dub just said was he didn't know what it was exactly.
Now, I think personally I think that would be fair. That's not
what Dubie said in that DM though, was it? Doobie didn't say,
"Well, I don't know what was posted. I don't know." Doobie lied
and said that was just where posted his TV blah blah. How the
like Dubbie might have been wrong, but I don't think Dubbie was
in terms of like the magnitude of the wrong that happened. I
don't think Dubbie is like very far off is is how I would explain
it. Did he even know that unless he's seen something himself
and if he hadn't seen the actual docks which you yourself say
he hasn't it means he got the talking point mentally into his
brain by justical or riitten house or any of these other losers.
That's exactly what happened. >> Okay. So
what I said what I what I said was the what I saw was not the
PV docs. And yes in the DMs I was sent or the messages I was
sent I don't know if they're DMs. Dubbie did say that it was
a PV docs. Now whether he lied or he was just grossly wrong I
can't say. I can't speak to that.
>> I Okay. Where did you get that ide?
That's fine. So Wick, to be clear, when you when they said this
to you, I asked you what it was, where it was, or who said it,
so that I could try to find their history on the server to figure
out if it was in there, if the user was in there, etc. Right.
Or if I think I see what server it was in, because we know that
the the leaks come from you, why did you say it was PV? >> Because
that's what I can I'm not aware of any stop talking. Stop talking.
I can tell you why. Okay. Because my only understand my understanding
is that that's the only time information has ever been put out.
I'm not aware of any dogs any other time ever. So when I was
told to put your reputation out there as the runner of the largest
apparently plucking discord on the internet
and I know you're really I say please stop talking to anything
you're saying you ramble on respond to it any of the random [__]
that you're [__] saying rambling okay thank you so
>> keep rambling keep rambling keep rambling keep okay
thank you bye >> with the word I'm totally fine with showing
those games like if you want to like so you can see people see
exactly what I so or any of our games like I don't have anything
to hide in there so um uh so what I said is >> I haven't
seen them post anything you're doxing when you come up with specifically
memes about eating noodles or something. I wouldn't tolerate
people doxing you. And then I said just figured out where it
came from. If you want to know, right? Because at that point
they they were talking about it on the server and they figured
out that it was like I posted in last September, right? And I
thought it was PB. That's what I thought. But they didn't when
they found it, they didn't post it. They just banned the person
that did it, right? When they found they didn't post it, they
banned the person that did it. My understanding was it was that
>> so dooby you understand that Destiny's argument is that
you were doing this in order to to kind of triangulate who is
leaking these things. >> So this is why that doesn't make
sense. I'm not stupid, but this why that doesn't make any sense.
So, if I take a screenshot of a Discord server and then send
it to you, unless my username is in the side chat or I'm replying
to something, how the are we going to know which user that came
from? >> Then why were you saying it was a PV doc? You
know, >> I just told you. >> Hey, everybody shut
the up. So, I'm going to make this point with Destiny here because
Destiny says, "Well, maybe Connor's kids could get docks based
off of this rationale." >> Whoa. I was not prescriptive.
I know, but I was just being descriptive, not prescriptive. Conor,
>> but it doesn't make any sense in a descriptive sense.
So, it's pretty obvious when you're not describing his belief,
right? You're not you're not describing his belief. If you're
not saying what is the descriptive reality that is led to by
him advocating for what he does, right? You're not doing any
of that. You're just making it up.
It's not attached to things he said. >> Anyone have I know,
but I'm just being descriptive. Not prescriptive. >> What
are you being descriptive about? >> This is why he's just
crashing out, right? He's just totally crashing out. Destiny,
go ahead. >> I'm just saying that you're creating an environment
that could facilitate harassment towards unrelated third parties
by >> But I'm not for this environment. I've criticized
this environment. I'm criticizing you for helping to foster this
environment. >> I know. I know that you're not for you.
You're just describing it. And I'm just describing your description.
That's >> correct. Correct. Correct. Correct. But but you
are actively engaged in doxing people. We know that those people
and their families could get hurt as a result of those reactions
if you're not.
And I'm criticizing you for doing that. So am I not trying to
get away from that >> No. You what a stupid you trying
to get away from it? >> No, you stupid [__]
>> You probably disassociate yourself completely from all
these people if you're a good faith actor. But seeing as how
this guy has only [__] you with $5,000 over the past
six months, I don't know what your incentive is right now. It's
really weird by the way that I'm arguing with two people that
this weirdo on disability child born consuming is literally funding.
is kind of hold test everybody now
dude they both took such offense to that they both got so mad
about that both of those
show you want to be kind of if you don't want to be associated
with it you wouldn't be associated with >> No let's go
ahead and do this let's see if you're capable of being honest
if you're capable of being honest let's see if you're capable
of being honest let's see if you're capable of being honest the
question completely can you steal man can you steal man why Dubie
said that he uh used uh child abuse material >> can you
articulate it without trying to cast the game as a pedoph
>> I don't think um I don't think Dub's on disability I
don't think disability goes that hard that you can donate like
thousands and thousands and thousands of dollars to people you
know what I'm saying I get a little bit but >> ask you
a question >> just saying I don't think so >> I'll
answer if you answer that question >> I yes I've seen casino
and I love it >> I would rather put my balls in the vice
that they use to pop that dude's eyes out of his head and crush
them then steel man anything this
aging stalker has ever done no I'm not going to steal being a
[__] perspectives. I'm not being to see someone head
on to it for a year. Like, who the [__] you calling
a pet? >> Yeah. [__] you talking about?
>> Dude. Dude, Connor just kicked Destiny. Connor just
kicked Destiny. Connor just kicked Destiny. Okay, it's over.
>> Pop that eyes and crush them. Then steel man anything
this
stalker has ever done. No, I'm not going to steal.
I'm not being >> held on to it for a year. Like, who the
[__] you going? >> Removed. Removed. Notice
how Destiny gets more feminine and when he is pressed. Yes. Yes,
I do. >> Hold on to it for a year. Like how? Why? Where
do you think I have any grand stand calling anybody? >> I
already kicked him. >> Oh, I'm sorry. >> Oh, you
so let me No, no, no. Wait. My turn. Thank you. >> He's
lying.
>> Destiny is bigger, has more viewers, has more money,
has more clout, has more influence. But if he was a peer, if
he was the same size, that's not how he would behave. If he was
asked to steal manand somebody else's position and he was a 50
viewer Andy or 150 viewer Andy and Wick forced him to as a debate
moderator, he would steamman the other person's position. And
all he's trying to do is say Doobie is my enemy right now. So
I'm going to go ahead and paint him as a and I am incapable
of describing what he described in his argumentation
as once again.
>> Wow.
Conor's like on the ball today. Conor's like totally on the ball
today. Conor's like shockingly on the ball today. It's out of
this world. >> I'll say this straight up. As Destiny's
fellow content creator, thank you for the content. Love the content.
Love the money. Thanks for the donations. Thanks for the 10,00k
live. As your friend, you're being a and I'm tired of it.